how's it going breasts - Pippa if you
think my hair looks stupid well then
you're absolutely correct correct that's
a word now apparently in the English
dictionary
alright Germany you ain't got on me
so I tweet it out
no i facebooked out for you brooch to
join this very server that we're playing
on right now and we will we will conquer
the duck will suck up everyone that's
right I'll suck up anyone for views
I forgot how MLG I am at this game look
how I got my together I really have
to pee it's not even bothering me oh my
god he almost ate me and then he's gonna
eat me oh my god did I get that
reference right I think yes
Ronaldo what did I told you about
sucking dick Ronaldo oh my god you
are you happy that was my my
12 year old demon that came out how is
this game so popular like I know
every youtuber and their mother has
played this but it's like it's fun but
it's it's not like you know what you
changed my life I feel bad for even
saying that
you piece of you
piece of oh boy
oh is it is it me around my sweating
balls are you sweating balls right now
is it my haircut is it doing is it
working for you suck my dick suck my
dick suck my dick oh you
did it
he nibble on it and I was like you like
that and me like thank you thank
you pat thank you for blessing me with
your giant penis don't you how dare you
how don't you dare touch my unsymmetric
nipple Bosnia if that even is your real
name Bosnia hey Nicky you got a nice
nipple there can I suck on it hey Nicky
come on Nicky I'm sweating why am i
sweating this much this is unnatural I
just took a shower I think it's like
after sweat it's still gross this is not
okay the sexual tension in this episode
is off the roof I think I need to need
to make a phone call if you know what I
mean I think I'm not gonna go beyond
that I don't like to party I like to
party who wants to party
come on let's party come on let's party
yeah yeah come on let's party oh that's
just too bad huh that's just too
bad you know what I am so upset
for you so upset so upset you know how
upset I am you see this tears
best real tears right
there
Jesus Christ should be an actress actor
actor okay Oh
number 10 we just popped up she could
suck my dick how about that oh god oh
god oh god oh god can we make it can we
make you can we make you can we make you
can we make it oh I just threw up in my
mouth
mana Baba you rest a just shock mop
stop looking good at this game this game
is all about holding your balls how was
that how was that for a change how was
that do the outer guard games
yeah but Arden even has a place
quality content this is interesting
oh god please merge please merge please
for the love of dicks in my
merge oh that was amazing can we
talk about that a bit about ba ba ba ba
ba ba ba ba ba Papa Papa skip it about
that